[Music]  and so when I went to showed up  I showed up actually in the wrong love  and it was waiting for Twain miss thanks  everybody why is nobody here and then I  get this frantic text from one of the  people think I got mad you were about to  shoot the video and I started school and  I remember the first day I was so  excited and I got my notebook out and  like my pencil bag and had it like on  the table because I thought I was in the  learn to read and write that first day  so I was just ready and the whole day  went by this is like instructions and  stuff like that I was kind of like that  but I thought from the larger reader my  expectation is just like that's a young  adults value like I'll go to school and  I'm nowhere to read right and I'm just  so excited  [Music]  you